[Music]
what is ukrainian literature how do we
know how old it is
how did the numerous language bands
influence its formation who are the
essential figures of ukrainian
literature
in this video we will follow the
chronology and describe the brightest
and most unique facts
sometimes your heart leads you it
dictates loves aches and shivers and
sometimes we will follow our wisdom and
intellect ukrainian literature though
oppressed and banned during the
centuries was robust original and
self-sufficient
[Music]
first of all we should specify what
ancient ruse was
ancient ruse is not the same as today's
russia
though the similarity of names is not a
coincidence
historically ruse is ancient ukraine
the name ukraine was used for the land
of kazakhs since about the mid-17th
century that's why the prominent
historian mikhail hushevsky used the
name ukraine ruse to underline ethnic
and historical continuity
as far as we know the name ukraine was
first mentioned in the cave chronicles
in 1187 but it became widespread only in
the early 20th century
from the 10th to 17th century most books
were written in religious institutions
so the literature of the time had its
clear function as early as in the tale
of bygone years chronicle
in books we learn in our instructed to
follow the path of penitence for wisdom
and temperance we gain from the written
words
the christian paradigm of course
influenced the genres of writing
sometimes the search of symbols and
allegories influenced the understanding
of the world
for example the author of the treaty's
physiologist described real as well as
fantastic creatures the stories were
full of biblical allegories rather than
biological facts
in those times the author was regarded
not as a writer but rather as the person
who realizes god's will
the time of old literature with all its
strange creatures is followed by the
printing age
the wave of renaissance culture reached
ukraine and triggered the rebirth of
national culture
in 1483 the book by ukrainian scientist
yuri kotermak director of the
prestigious university of bologna is
published
though it was an astrological pamphlet
in latin named the clear prognostic for
the current year 1483 it was the first
printed book written by a ukrainian
the start was initiated in 1491 the
first cyrillic texts were printed
and finally in 1574 in review ivan
fedorovich printed the first book in
ukraine apostle in the first dictionary
in eastern slavic lands buchvar
[Music]
then in the late 16th to early 17th
century ukrainian culture is dominated
by the baroque style the word barroco
means a pearl of a bizarre form
something both precious and eccentric
in ukraine during that time the baroque
style was everywhere
in religious architecture in art in
fashion and in language
and of course in literature where the
dominant traditional spiritual component
is playfully combined with classical
mythology
in poetry it is a time of syllabic verse
which has an equal number of syllables
in every line
authors play an experiment with poetic
forms the champion of this was yvonne
velichkovsky this is how he managed to
incorporate his name into one of his
poems look at the yellow letters
historical songs and epic sung poems
dumas are very popular
and the kubzars the singers who perform
them play in the kobza or bandura become
very important figures in full culture
the kubzad will become a true archetype
of ukrainian literature and in the
baroque era the common roots language
became more widely used
in text it gradually becomes more
widespread than the bookish slavic ruse
language the ukrainian version of chirk
slavik
but in 1720 ukraine being a part of the
russian empire sarah peter the first
will ban printing of any books in
ukrainian
half a century later in 1775
russian troops will destroy the main
kozak stronghold zaporizian siege
[Music]
the unruly element of burlesque is
raging in ukrainian literature the
nineteenth century shows that lowly
things are able to express lofty ideas
laughter even had something sacred in it
the question was posed by her horizon
jesus ever laughed
and he had his answer
it was yes
the key figure of that period is yvonne
kotyarebsky he works on the remake of
virgil's the anayd
this epic and burlesque poem shows that
humor and the ability to laugh in any
situation is in the ukrainian national
psyche
and the choice of kotlerevskay's
imitators to write in this style and in
ukrainian
demonstrated their separation from the
context of the russian empire
the element of ukrainian humor storms
into the russian empire with mikola
goggle gogol teaches russia to laugh
but it's not only about laughing and
pleasure in the 19th century the main
canonic figures of ukrainian literature
and conscience arise
they are tarashev chenko lasse ukrinka
and ivan franco tarashevchenko is called
kobzar even during his own lifetime
he came from a simple background and
wrote for them he was the embodiment of
collective memory the fighter for truth
and justice ivan franco gets the name
the rock breaker a realist and atheist
an active person with focused ideas of
society
and also a poet writer
translator and scholar
for the hundreds of his masks franco had
about a hundred pen names
and lassie okrinka a well-educated and
noble woman she was nicknamed the
daughter of prometheus
the embodiment of power of spirit and
endurance a strong feminist
these three figures are so meaningful
and important to ukrainian literature
that they still stand in spite of all
the attempts of following generations to
desacralize and dethrone them
and if speaking about the icons of
ukrainian literature there are many more
than just three
even beyond goggle it has a lot of
memorable and diverse personalities and
texts the kaidash family by ivan nichoy
lewitsky has been an archetypal family
saga for already two centuries
it still feels quite contemporary
or meet olija kobelanska
who was on the wave of the start of
ukrainian feminism today she still
attracts the attention of more and more
readers
mikhail kozubinski is remembered not
only as the author of the shadows of
forgotten ancestors filmed by siddhi
paraganov and yuri elienko but also as a
master of timeless psychological prose
the city written by valerian
piedmohelene is a bright urbanistic
novel proving that ukrainian literature
is not only about rural life
in the 1920s ukrainian literature was
booming it was a fruitful time for
detective and love stories sci-fi
women's pros and travel reports
entire genres returned and showed the
power and self-sufficiency of ukrainian
literature
the ukrainian avant-garde is asserting
itself internationally
it's often the case that ukrainian
literature forms in spite of
circumstances as rebellion
it often had to overcome bans
repression and colonial influence that's
how it was formed
for instance
valuev's decree banning the publishing
of any religious and popular books in
ukrainian
the m's decree was the ban to publish
and import any literature in ukrainian
original or translated
little changed after the fall of the
russian empire
the soviet system had been arresting and
repressing the ukrainian people of the
arts and letters for a long time
generations of dissidents cherished a
dream of ukraine enduring prison and
torture by the authorities they
literally risked their lives
one of the greatest ukrainian poets
vasel stuss
was tortured to death in prison in 1985.
the final publication of his poetry in
the ussr during his lifetime was in 1966
in the donbass journal
the next one came out four years after
his death in 1989
that seems like almost yesterday
some friends of the poet are still alive
and so are his killers
due to constant bans to historical
turbulence and finally because people
always look for a better life
ukrainian literature was written not
only in ukraine
in the 1920s after a wave of emigration
caused by the defeat of the national
liberation struggle the prague school
was formed
it was then that the distinct feature of
ukrainian literature and exile became
apparent
those authors were creating an
alternative to official soviet
literature
it does not follow the compulsory canon
of socialist realism it takes up the
trends of the world's top literature to
criticize the soviet system
another powerful wave of ukrainian
immigrant writers was caused by the
second world war
in the refugee camps of the mostly
american occupation zone which held
about 200 000 ukrainians the ukrainian
art movement was formed its ukrainian
acronym was mur it lasted for three
years during that time more than twelve
hundred books and pamphlets had been
written and published in the times of
moore
tiger hunters by ivan parriane
dr cereficus and without the ground by
viktor domontovic and aust by ulas
samchuk were written or first published
in the 1950s a new literary movement the
new york group was formed
its members were people born in ukraine
but educated in the west after the war
these people associated themselves with
new york that is with the dynamics
cosmopolitanism artistic avant-garde and
fascination with the vibe of the
sprawling metropolis
in 1961 the magazine such as nist was
founded in munich
it had been published for 30 years in
germany then in the united states this
journal became one of the most important
platforms for ukrainian diaspora
intellectuals
the role of ukrainian ambassador was
taken by the ukrainian free university
in munich the canadian institute of
ukrainian studies the ukrainian research
institute of harvard university
this is what ukrainian-american slavic
scholar yuri chevaliev said about
ukrainian literature in exile if we
could not have our homeland on the map
we could build it in our souls
and that they did
symbolically ukrainian post-modernism
started according to one view after the
chernobyl disaster
because people of letters tried to fight
the feeling of the apocalypse with irony
and the new approach to understanding
both the role of the writer and the very
idea of literature
in the mid-1980s new literary groups
were formed the most well-known was
founded by yuri andrujovic viktor
neborak and alexander irvanettes a year
before the chernobyl disaster it was
called bubabu for burlesque balagon
cheap show buffoonery
it did much for the development of irony
as a weapon against established cliches
and restrictions
alexander irvanettes made a mockery of
the socialist canon one of his key
styles
yuri androkovich's novel recreations and
moscoviada became two important texts
for understanding the ukrainian
post-colonial discourse
an even harsher laugh was that of les
podervianski's the witty and universal
formulas for describing reality from his
plays are still used today
but chernobyl is not the only starting
point for modern ukrainian literature
such a point could be the founding of
the magazine chitwad thursday in 1989.
it gathered a community of talented
authors
many of them were from ivanovsk
the original name of the city was
stanislav so this collective was
nicknamed the stanislaw phenomenon or we
can start in 1996 when the novel field
work in ukrainian sex by aksana zabushko
now internationally famous was first
published
but no matter what date we choose
ukraine of the 1990s and ukraine at the
beginning of the 21st century is an
ideology-free space of play with old
colonial myths players harnessing them
for their own aesthetic tasks irony
parody and carnival is our everything
plus some uncontrolled element of
ukrainian burlesque
2014 changed everything
after the revolution of dignity the
annexation of crimea and the hybrid
russian ukrainian war
several radical transformations in
society culture and of course literature
have taken place
writers go to war
and some defenders of ukraine who
probably had never imagined themselves
in literature before are transforming
their experience into texts the most
interesting literary phenomena of recent
years is about understanding the war and
its consequences one way or another
a few famous books in the 21st century
however strange and sad they may be
appear in the tradition of the memoirs
written in soviet prison camps or about
them
this reality is so eventful that
ukrainian non-fiction and essays have
been flourishing in recent years
ukrainians are increasingly aware of
their identity as a result we are more
interested in our history art traditions
and novelty in all their manifestations
after maidan new cultural institutions
are formed
a lot of small niche publishing houses
are founded some new and experimental
ways of literary distribution are tried
new literary festivals take place all
over the country
the boom of ukrainian literature still
goes on
and if this process is not interrupted
then very soon we will have a generation
that will not need to start everything
all over again
this generation will be able to live a
long and happy life
realizing all their dreams
and they will have readers who will
discover ukrainian literature and accept
it as their own
these ukrainian readers will feel that
they have things to be proud of to write
about and to dream about
and that we ukrainians have memories and
new stories to share with the world
because ukrainian literature is a heart
and mind that fights together
works together
beats together works in unison
together they create whole worlds